a couple decides to adopt a boy named
cody but they soon realize that the
boy's dreams come literally true
including his nightmares
today on cinema recapped i'll show you
before i wake up
the film begins with a child sleeping
when suddenly his father enters the room
with the intention of harming him
however something opens the door and
interrupts him
then we see a couple named jessie and
mark who want to adopt a child and the
social worker tells them that she has
the ideal child for them the couple
seems to agree
that night through the memories of the
woman we see that the couple had a son
before but that he died in an accident
since he slipped and drowned in the
bathtub
the next day the adopted boy arrives and
we see that he is the same boy from the
beginning of the film
he greets them very kindly and we see
that he's very polite and even takes off
his shoes before entering the house
the couple shows the boy the whole house
including his room and the boy seems to
be very happy
at night they take him to bed but the
boy takes out an energy drink from among
his things to stay up all night
the next day they take the boy named
cody to school where he sees his new
classmates
after a while he returns home and takes
a bath
meanwhile jesse picks up cody's room and
notices that he's having drinks and
pills to avoid sleep
at night mark talks to cody about a book
about butterflies and then jesse comes
over to talk to him telling him that she
saw that he takes pills and drinks to
keep from sleeping
so she asks him why he does that and
cody tells you that he doesn't like to
sleep
he says that he doesn't want to sleep
because when he does a monster comes out
and eats people and that this monster
even ate his mom
jesse explains that there's nothing to
fear and takes away the pills
later the couple is watching tv when
suddenly they see that many butterflies
appear in the room the man manages to
catch one of these butterflies but then
they all disappear without a trace
they go to bed but jessie can't sleep
so she goes to get some water and starts
hearing strange noises
she looks into the kitchen and sees a
boy running
then she goes to see cody
but he's asleep
jessie thinks that she saw the ghost of
her dead son who's angry because they
brought a new child home and feels
replaced
so she talks about it in her therapy but
her instructor tells her there may have
been a dream
or a figment of her imagination because
jesse hasn't been sleeping well lately
meanwhile cody is at school drawing a
butterfly when suddenly they bring a
child who seems to be problematic to the
classroom and punish him
but cody decides not to pay attention to
him and continues drawing
that night cody asks them who the boy in
one of the paintings is
and the couple explains that he's their
son but that he passed away and is in
heaven
cody goes to sleep while the couple
stays watching tv again in the living
room
then the couple gets surprised because
suddenly the deceased son appears in the
middle of the room
looking at them they approach to touch
him and realize that he's real
they hug him very happily but at that
moment cody wakes up and as a
consequence the couple's son disappears
they get very confused and at that
moment cody enters apologizes for what
happened and takes an energy drink to
his room
the couple go to bed
and talk about what they saw
then the next day the family has lunch
and both mark and jesse look at cody
strangely
the boy apologizes to them for having
dreamt
and it's then that the couple
understands that the things they saw in
the house are cody's dreams come true
jessie wishes she could hear her son so
that afternoon she shows cody a video
where the boy can be seen at a christmas
party so that cody can hear his voice
and the next time he dreams imagine the
boy's voice so that the couple can talk
to him
that night jesse puts cody to bed and
then the couple stay up to wait in the
living room
after a moment they see some colorful
butterflies again and then their son
appears happy and talking
jessie is very happy with her son's
return although mark does not seem to be
very convinced
and at that moment we see some of the
butterflies form a monster and enter the
boy's room to tell him that he'll always
be with him
causing cody to wake up
the next day cody draws this monster
which he calls the canker man because he
says that if he draws it and scratches
it he'll stay away when he gets home
mark realizes that jesse has put all of
the paintings of his dead son back so
that cody sees them more often and
therefore dreams of him more often
mark tries to make his wife see that
they should not use cody as a projector
to see their deceased son because they
should also think about cody and his
feelings
he also tells her that they promise to
take care of cody and that the boy they
see is not really their son but a
representation that cody makes in his
dreams
jesse doesn't listen to him and instead
tells him that she will continue to see
the boy
the next day cody goes to school when
suddenly he meets the troublesome child
he throws a jar that he brought with a
butterfly so cody decides to push him
and then cody goes to his classroom but
is very sleepy since he didn't sleep
last night
he falls asleep in class
then the problematic child appears to
take revenge on cody taking advantage of
the fact that he's asleep but at that
moment the canker man appears and eats
him
and this is seen by one of the other
kids
jesse goes to pick up cody from school
and when they get home the boy feels
guilty because he knows the canker man
was at school when he slept and he feels
responsible for the disappearance of his
classmate
mark tries to talk to cody and then goes
to sleep while jesse stays in the living
room to wait for the boy to fall asleep
and therefore see their dead son
but cody drinks a lot of coffee and
doesn't sleep
cody stays up that night looking at his
butterfly book
suddenly he hears a noise under the bed
he looks but doesn't find anything and
when he sits back on the bed a monster
behind him yells at him
cody falls out of the bed scared while
the monster starts scratching his feet
so cody starts yelling that he's awake
so the ghost will disappear the next day
some policemen arrive at the family's
house to talk to cody about the
classmate who disappeared
and then cody and mark build a new bed
shaped as a car
that night jesse decides to give cody a
glass of milk but she puts some sleeping
pills in it so he starts to feel sleepy
and is taken to bed
before leaving the room mark tells the
boy how his other son died he tells him
that he drowned in the bathtub because
cody was curious about that
the couple talks for a while in the
living room before going to sleep
suddenly they see their son
something is strange and jesse
approaches him but at that moment a
liquid pours forth from his mouth
then the canker man appears so mark runs
to wake up cody so that the monster will
leave
harvard doesn't wake up because he's
very much asleep due to the pills
jesse tells her husband that she gave
pills to the boy and both lock
themselves in the room so the monster
does not enter
however the canker man opens the door
and mark tries to fight him the monster
ends up devouring him and then hitting
jessie
she falls unconscious on the floor and
when she wakes up she sees cody is very
scared
after a while the police arrive and they
ask jesse what happened
but she doesn't know what to tell them
the police proceed to take cody because
they believe that jesse heard him and
her husband the next day jesse goes to
talk to the social worker to ask her
where cody is
but she's very angry because they told
her that jesse drugged the kid with
pills
getting no help from the social worker
jessie decides to steal cody's documents
to see if she can find him that way but
then she realizes that he had other
families before
jesse decides to go see a man who
adopted cody in the past and we see that
it's the same man for the beginning of
the movie
he tried to kill cody and he's now at a
psychiatric hospital
jesse asks him what he knows about cody
and it's then that the man tells her
that when he and his wife adopted cody
they also realize that their dreams come
true but also
their nightmares
he tells her that one day his wife was a
little sick and cody got upset about it
that night a monster came and ate her
since then he could only see his wife
while cody dreamt
but cody did not remember her well so in
his dreams he'd given her a stranger's
face
the man says that the child should be
dead so that he can't harm anyone else
but that he couldn't kill him
jessie refuses to kill cody stating that
she'll find another way to get rid of
the monster she begins to investigate
who his biological mother was
she arrives at a hospital where cody's
mother was hospitalized before she died
and begins to read the file about her
then she asks them to let her take the
woman's last belongings and when she
gets home she sees the contents of the
box
she finds a butterfly
a pair of shoes and a diary
meanwhile the social worker sedates cody
because he's not wanting to sleep for
several nights
cody then falls asleep and butterflies
start to come out all over the place
jesse arrives where coney is staying and
starts looking for him suddenly she
hears her dead son talking to her from a
bathroom
jesse enters the bathroom and approaches
the tub seeing her eyeless son drowning
in the water but the woman decides to
leave finally accepting the death of her
son
she keeps looking for cody and on a
monitor in one of the rooms she sees
cody dreaming about her and her husband
but he's dreaming that she's
manipulating him to transform him into
her son
implying just how uncomfortable cody
felt because he knew that jesse only
wanted him so she could see her dead son
jesse gets out of there and continues
walking through the corridors until she
finds the room where cody actually is
however that moment the canker man
appears and throws jessie out of the
room
the monster runs towards jessie intent
on eating her but jesse takes a
butterfly out of her pocket the same one
that belonged to cody's mom and the
monster stops to see it
and jesse approaches and hugs the canker
man and little by little the monster
turns into cody and then disappears
jesse goes in to find the real cody who
is still sleeping and takes him out of
that place once they're home jesse
explains to cody everything that
happened that his mom took care of him
when he was little but the one day she
got cancer
she also tells him that when his mom was
very ill she said goodbye to cody and
told him that she would always be with
him
but cody was too young to understand
that his mom had gotten sick so he
thought a monster had killed her and
confused the word cancer with canker
that's why he called the monster the
canker man
then jesse tells him that now she's
going to take care of him and that
she'll never use him to see her dead son
anymore the end
if you liked this video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best drama and horror
movies
thanks for watching